[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
intersectionality actually
came out of my
effort to think about
how to
create a word picture
so that people could understand what
happens when the kind of inequality that
they're prepared to deal with
overlaps or has an encounter with the
kind of inequality that they're not
committed to haven't even thought about
don't experience themselves and don't
necessarily feel called
upon to be present in that
intersectionality is also a frame it's a
frame that gives us a greater uh sense
of how certain social problems come
about and importantly what needs to be
rethought in terms of the conventional
interventions that we create for those
inequalities when those interventions
come out of narrow or
non-intersectional frames i came across
a case that featured a woman named emma
degraffenreid she was actually
representing an entire group of black
women who were seeking better employment
opportunities at an auto manufacturing
plant in the midwest she was
a wife she was a mom she was working
class she was really hoping to advance
her family's well-being by seeking a
different kind of job than the ones that
typically were set aside for a woman
like her
a job as a domestic worker or a job as a
janitorial
engineer these were the kinds of jobs
that were underpaid and that were
usually without benefits they weren't
the kind of job that would allow you to
actually entertain a middle class
aspiration so she was trying to get one
of those better manufacturing jobs so
she applied for the job
unlike other black women
she was denied
after her denial she sued the employer
claiming race and gender discrimination
now
the judge that heard emma's case
dismissed her suit
and he dismissed her suit because the
employer in question had in fact
hired african-americans
and the employer had in fact
hired women
from the court's vantage point
the fact that they'd hired african
americans
and had hired women
meant that they did not engage in race
discrimination and they didn't engage in
gender discrimination
now the fact that the african-americans
they hired were not women
and the women that they hired were not
african-americans
didn't defeat the argument that these
women were unable to prove
discrimination because the employer had
hired blacks and had hired women
so from the court's vantage point the
problem was that
for emma to be able to say i was
discriminated against she had to say i
was discriminated against as a black
person who's a woman
i was discriminated against as a woman
who's a black person
that's what she would have had to say
and the court thought that the law
didn't allow her to combine these two
causes of action into one
but the fact that no
judge ever stopped to think
well why is this not a symmetrical
disability how come
a y-class plaintiff can represent all
women even though there are differences
within them but a woman of color can't
represent everyone and the same with
respect to men so in so so what we had
here was a problem
of the of the belief that women of color
were a category in and of themselves
they could not represent themselves
on their own nor could they represent
all women are all men and this is the
moment when i really started thinking
about pre-existing schemas you've heard
about the story um about um
the uh the father who rushes his son
to the hospital who's had an accident
and uh the surgeon begins to operate and
then realizes oh no i can't it's my son
and you know everyone's stumped by this
how can the father you know rush him to
the hospital and the surgeon says he's
my son too
until it hits you duh the surgeon is a
woman but that it it takes that extra
moment
for it to lock into place now just add
into that
uh race
um class any other kind of schema that
takes even longer for it to lock in that
your pre-existing assumptions about who
this person was
um were all wrong that's the space for
intersectionality